Louisa
Montalvo 37
strangers 37 strangers Louisa
Montalvo thank you contest chair you're
welcome
clear
clear we have a female unresponsive no
pulse contest chair fellow Toast Masters
from around the world and
guests two years ago a horrific
automobile accident and that
unresponsive female was
me for 6 minutes my heart stopped
beating best sleep
[Laughter]
ever my co- driver and I had just
finished dropping off 88 homeless
shelter dogs to a dog rescue in New
Jersey on the the way back as I sat in
the passenger seat of the van that's
when the accident
happened as I lay there
unconscious 37 strangers in the way of
firefighters EMT Specialists helicopter
Pilots surgeons
nurses all came together to try to save
my life because
death it's so final
now I don't recall anything because I
was asleep but those six minutes ah my
imagination ran away from me and I can
almost imagine what happened with me
trying to get into heaven probably went
like
this I'm standing there in front of the
Pearly
Gates St Peter's on his
iPad I can even see my God in the
background playing with his dogs oh and
I say my God because I don't want to
offend some of you I want to offend all
of
[Laughter]
you St Peter I'm Louisa Montalvo St
Peter says I I don't even have you on
the agenda hang
on he goes back to talk to God and says
God Louisa Montalvo is here and God says
I don't have anybody for two minutes he
says wait a minute St Peter was this a
car accident
St Peter says yes it was Louisa montavo
makes sense have you ever seen a
[Laughter]
drive no no God she was the
passenger H Louisa is she the one trying
to save my homeless dogs in
Texas yes God that's
her God leans over waves at me and says
Louisa today's not your day
it's not your time he leans over to St
Peter's
iPad and hits the reset
button at that moment I'm imagining that
that's when they take that final attempt
to try to get me to save my life put the
petals on me
clear and I start to breathe
again now for the next 90 days I'm in a
trauma center and in rehab facility
questioning my
life what was my value what was I
worth I couldn't even
walk what good was
I and then it hit me I'm rolling myself
into the gym ready to work out that
final week before I go home and even
though my father said quitters
cry I started to
cry I I wheel myself to my machine I
start working out and this young
handsome man is working out next to me
hi how are you doing I'm getting married
soon I have Hazard listened to his
wedding plans and then I start to ask
myself why is he even here he looks so
young and
fit and just like that I look down and
realized he's just recently lost both of
his
legs and yet here he was with a smile on
his face happy he'd been given a second
chance and life was not going to get
away from me he wasn't going to waste a
single
minute
wow I know a lot of us go through life
and sometimes we even question
our
value why are we even here but if 37
strangers were able to see the value in
me all their positive
input I am now making that part of my
output because you know we will listen
to a stranger that tells us we have
value before we listen to
ourselves it's true
if you're needing some stranger to tell
you you have
value allow me to be that
stranger because if 37 people can come
together and put all this energy into me
can you imagine what 1,700 of us could
accomplish all it is is treating each
other other with
dignity and
worth how awesome would it be if we
could all be United like
this every
day if you're ready to hit that reset
button if you're looking for that second
chance let's hit that reset button are
you ready
clear
clear Adam to
[Applause]